le jardin botanique de la réunion
propose divers animations pour les
enfants pendant les vacances scolaires
parmi elles un jeu de découverte pour
mieux comprendre les joyaux de la
litière
les enfants sont amenés à découvrir la
flore indigène et l'écosystème
souterrain grâce au jeu au dessin et aux
plantations
alors la hier c'est la partie on va
dire donc ce lac banque sur laquelle on
marche tous les jours sans y prêter
attention et c'est une on va dire donc
une couche en fait du sol et qui est
surtout composée en va de matières
organiques en décomposition et donc
c'est cette matière organique aussi dans
laquelle on voit donc beaucoup d'êtres
vivants et aussi bien les graines qui
peuvent effectivement prendre racine et
germé et la litière
malheureusement c'est vrai qu'on la
foule tous les jours et sans vraiment se
poser la question de savoir de quoi il
s'agit personne effectivement ne va
associer la litière à la notion
d'écosystème et pourtant on a bien un
monde de petits mondes dans cette
mission
on va aller en fait rencontrer ce qu'il
ya sous la terre a déjà vu ce qu'il y
avait sur la tête ce qui est que des
insectes sous la terre non mais moi ce
que je trouve pas ça dit d'aller tout au
long des essais n'aspirez l'araignée
voilà en fait c'est ton côté tu aspires
et de l'autre aspyr fort mardi les
enfants dont les amène à découvrir en
fait dali tir par eux mêmes
il faut aller chercher ce qui est sous
les feuilles se poser des questions sur
les petites bêtes qu'il ya dessous sur
les graines qui sont en décomposition
donc et sort de là avec donc ils vont
exprimer ce qu'ils ont vu non parce que
leur art encore raconté donc voila un
petit peu le but et après ben alors
l'idée c'est vraiment éveillé les
enfants à ce patrimoine donc durable qui
est sûre donc la litière un atelier
ludique et animé qui permet de
sensibiliser les jeunes aux enjeux
environnementaux ainsi qu aux enjeux de
préservation de l'écosystème
si tu es bien ça nous apprend des choses
sur les insectes et sur la terre j'ai
compris que les insectes lui faisait
faille
il faisait la terre sans eau bay aurait
peut-être pas de terre et aussi c'est
aussi faux pas de il faut pas mettre des
produits chimiques sur la terre sinon
les aztèques vont mourir et peut-être
que yo rapide car après cette animation
s'inscrit dans le cadre de l'année
internationale des sols la découverte
des joyaux de la litière est aussi
proposé lors des visites guidées du
jardin botanique